how did you how did you stumble into
acting
like at day 16 of your modeling you know
when did i was one of the opportunities
for something come to you i was modeling
i was doing commercials and catalog i
wasn't a fashion i wasn't like a
editorial model i was like making a
really decent living for a young girl
who never saw money in her life you know
you mean to like make money doing a
catalog and and
and and commercials and i went to live
in paris and i was there for a year and
i never worked except for one one job
and i'm convinced that they just thought
i was not going to return from morocco
is why they sent me there they were like
who hasn't worked this entire year let's
send her if she doesn't come back it'll
no no harm
didn't get the job i came home to do my
taxes whilst i was home i went to my
agency which here i worked all the time
worked every single day
and my agent my commercial agent said
hey they're casting a movie they want to
see girls
will you go in and read for the part and
it was for the mask
and so
i didn't read for the main part
originally but i i ended up going back
and reading for the
the female lead chuck russell the
director was amazing he just basically
said like i want it was down they were
trying to get anna nicole smith
to do it because at the time jim carrey
was still a white dude from in living
color yeah um pet detective hadn't come
out yet this venture hadn't come out yet
so they were basically trying to get
like a a female star in the role
somebody else somebody that they knew
here's this like like la commercial
actress that chuck russell was like she
is my tina carlisle i want her and he
took me through the entire process like
i was doing wardrobe and
i was 20. and i turned 21 on the set of
the mask and he basically was like
you're
going to be my tina you're gonna be my
tina just keep coming i was doing dance
rehearsal i was doing you know wardrobe
fittings i was doing everything i still
hadn't got the job yet
and it was basically like two weeks
before they were starting to film they
said you got the job how long did you go
through the process how long did you go
it was like
a month or
two i think by the way i understand what
you just said
this can be the demise
of an actor or actress okay when you
when you are acting as if you have said
part
and you haven't been given said part
it's a very dangerous space but i wasn't
an actress that's my point model but you
then you're you're you're engulfed into
this now dream yeah oh my god it was
really exciting so you want me to go
yeah you want me to go meet yeah you
want me to go talk yeah and it just
keeps progressing and progressing yeah
it was really wild it was just sort of
like all of a sudden i was like
i'm not i don't consider myself a really
competitive person but i really just
thought it was so much fun i had i'd
never gotten the rush that i had gotten
when i was doing that you know by
acting with jim carrey you know what i
mean and i said you know
all right okay i didn't even know what
it meant i didn't know what making a
movie meant i didn't even know how to
hit him like i knew how to hit a mark
from doing commercials but like
acting wasn't my thing i never done it
before are you kidding me so this wasn't
even
this wasn't the plan this was never the
plan i was not trying to act wow i was
not i was doing commercials and i was
like okay i guess so sure uh you know
and then i was just like this is fun
i'll do it sure great and then after i
did it i had such
i had never had a sense of community
before because as an as a model we would
be on a you know uh shoot for maybe a
week and then you'd never see the people
again but you know how it is on us on a
set
no yeah you know how it is you know when
they're just like
[Laughter]
why are y'all laughing
that wasn't joel no no it wasn't a joke
no i don't understand my question
problem it's it's honestly guys i
remember working with him at the end of
my career you have no idea the modeling
jobs that i had
go google hard body
hard body 1993
and you tell me if i had a modeling
career sorry cameron it's just a lot of
attitude i understand you have to keep
them you know in line it's just a lot
so did it click after that that
this is now
yeah this could be my career
this is yeah then i was like then i was
like this is fun i want to do this this
is what i want to do
and so i got an agent and i
you know was basically like i don't want
to do the parts they're going to ask me
to do okay those are not the parts i
want to do okay whoever asked like my
first offer i got after the mask was to
play like a scientist
you know like a sexy scientist you know
from russia you know
you know we're like yeah exactly you
know perfect
i'm from long beach and that [ __ ] is not
i can't even barely move my tongue is so
lazy but how are you how are you so in
the know at this point to like yo i know
i they're gonna say i don't want because
i because i because i'm a woman and i'm
objectified constantly and sexualized
constantly and i was like i don't want
to do that
[Music]
you